complete and utter capitulation.
Why does she I Does she not understand like probably just don't
bring that up? Especially don't bring that up on stream. And
every DGG'er, every single DGG'er, crying about this, crying
about my coverage of this. Taylor Lorenz won, Destiny lost. He
totally got destroyed.
That's fine. That like if that's your perspective, that's okay.
My standard for journalism is that Hi. No, no, this is your This
is sloppy journalism you're >> Destiny, I freelance from
the mainstream media. I can't I just wrote a big piece for Vanity
Fair and the Guardian last week. I can't write for those organizations
if I was accepting dark >> Well, first of all, yes, you
can. Of course, you can. You don't have to declare every single
income source or any Of course, you can. Yeah, of course, you
can. >> Uh what we can say for sure is every single DGG'er
who tried to argue with me that Taylor Lorenz takes dark money,
all of you can fill out an apology form, okay, and send it to
me on Discord,
Just fill out the apology form. Every single one of you tried
to argue that Taylor Lorenz takes dark money.
Is the guy who told you that originally realized he sounded like
a total [__]
totally went back on it, and now has capitulated entirely that
Taylor Lorenz doesn't take dark money. So, when he kept telling
her, "You take dark money. You take dark money. You take dark
No. All right, let's um let's do the substance clips then. At
The OmniLiberal's debate performance against Taylor Lorenz was
so pitiful that the usual suspects that make up the cast of some
of Destiny's most ardent sweepers can't seem to keep the defense
together and are now resorting between extreme coping,
I guess flip-flopping between extreme coping or criticizing Destiny's
own misunderstandings for why he took another L to Taylor Lorenz,
featuring Counter Points, Tom Foolery, and I don't know who the
other person is. >> And so, I don't think that Destiny
is necessarily actually stating that this is a dark money group.
I think he's pretending to be an idiot in order to use the same
kind of insults that Taylor >> He's pretending to be an
idiot.
Dude, that's rough. That's That's rough when that's Connor's
That's very rough when that's Connor's best defense. I believe
he was pretending to be an
>> Ransom and Somer Goth have used against other creators
against Taylor Lorenz. So, I I think all that's If I had to guess,
he's pretending to be an idiot. He doesn't actually think it's
dark money, but may maybe he'll come out and be like, "No, no,
no, it is dark money." Like I don't know. We'll see.
>> Now, so uh Sorry, who was it Schlep said? I do think
that's accurate though. There's some element of that which is
like possibly true that he knew it wasn't dark money and he was
just being annoying and bad faith in the conversation, right?
Definition of Definitionally bad faith. Possibly.
Not in like a I'm a rich way, just in a petulant child kind of
way.
>> Possibly. Like I don't know. We'll see. >> Very
[__] annoying uh to to listen to her make a bunch
of points that are untrue again in their conversation and Destiny
miss on all of the things that are actually untrue and keep pushing
on the things that are that he's wrong on. Like Like his claims
on the [__] >> Dude, Tom came in and said some
really dumb [__] It sounded like Tom did a bunch
of research and knew how like all the funding stuff was connected
together.
I don't know if any of that was true, by the way. But it sounded
like Tom knew all of the funding stuff, right? And then he started
saying [__] like Taylor Lorenz said that they all
obviously they disclosed that they were paid by Chorus. And so,
if she doesn't think that's dark money group, then why is she
even upset? And it's like, "No, a foundational part of the article
is that the contracts include a non-disclosure clause that prevents
them from disclosing that they work for Chorus or says you have
to ask Chorus to
Right? Like disclosure's a major part of the article.
to to listen to her make a bunch of points that are untrue again
in their conversation and Destiny miss on all of the things that
are actually untrue and keep pushing on the things that are that
he's wrong on. Like Like his claims on the [__] Media
Matters. Like he is he is just wrong. Like Omidyar does not qualify
as dark money, not under her definition, not under anybody's
definition. It just does not qualify as dark money at all. >> I think
Destiny's getting confused or maybe maybe I'm wrong, but the
guy Omidyar, the guy with the last name Omidyar, he has donated
like $40 million to the what is it called? The 1630 Fund? But
I don't think that the group that she is a part of, like this
incubator program for journalists, it's like a journalist cohort,
I think that is directly funded by that Omidyar guy, but it's
not technically dark money. Omidyar
>> That goes through another organization, but I think
that's all transparent >> most transparent organizations
to ever exist. And so it's just not it's just not a good argument
to keep pushing. >> The funny thing is is it's transparent
and people are like, well, Taylor says she knows where her money
comes from. And so like Taylor Lorenz is making a claim that
she knows where the money comes from. So she has to be able to
prove that Pierre Omidyar is the only funder. And it's like,
dude, this is again I the comparison I keep making for people
is it's sort of like if you worked at the Washington Post, it's
like do you know exactly where all of your money comes from,
how it's sourced like precisely?
No, Jeff Bezos is involved, he owns the Washington Post. Are
you taking dark money from Jeff Bezos somehow because he It's
like, no. >> And I had this conversation with a number
of content creators who stopped pushing the Omidyar thing because
they also did not realize how wrong this thing was, but they
just kind of copied Destiny and repeated the the [__]
that he was
That's a very good point from Tom. Yes, many people did do that.
Many complete
ones did that. I'll give Tom his laurels on this one. He did
not fall into that trap, right? Tom didn't do that. So Taylor
says it's very funny to see his own stands explain how wrong
and dumb he is. I know his I know many influencers are quite
allergic to fact-checking, but even they are like, how is this
he this ignorant?
How is he this ignorant? That's a good clip. Without further
ado, I think we can just get into this stuff. I think we can
get into whatever this coverage is, this chorus stuff. Here's
the first timestamp for when the horn Sanchez
hops into the call. >> What's your issue with T-Dog? >> Dude,
my my whole thing is that I I like I watched the 2 hours of torture
that you unfortunately had to put us through and I I just don't
think that there's any way that that woman is going to [__]
She's She's just so unserious. Like I >> Uh it's going
to be so funny cuz now we've seen a little bit of this stuff,
right? We've seen like a little more of this and Destiny's realized
that his the way he was talking about dark money and the way
his like fans are talking about it, they tried to take what he
said and run with it
and they look stupid. Everybody's mocking them. A bunch of people
around Destiny will be like, "You're wrong." And so he's got
to figure out how to tell Z, who is just a total zombie, doesn't
have like uh internal monologue, just latches on to other people,
right? He's got to find a way to let Z down and say like, "Oh,
actually Z, I don't agree with the thing I said yesterday. I
know you're copying me, but I actually don't agree with what
I said yesterday." So he's got to find a way how to like back
out of this and that's basically going to be what this conversation
is, is him trying to back out of that previous definition he
gave of dark money, the previous way he talked about dark money.
And now Z's going to come in really hot wanting to talk and he's
like, "Ah, but I need to not get totally dragged over the coals
like being a So he's got to back out. That's the dance we're
going to watch here, okay? >> I can't even. I mean, an
LLC is dark money whether you like it or not. I don't care if
she takes dark money. That is not my problem. I don't care. You
can take dark money all you want. My issue with her is that she
lies about it. >> And that she makes fun of people that
are also >> So she doesn't take money from that LLC. I'm
not totally sure how the other pack works or the other organization
works that she does take it. It's like Democracy Voice Now or
something. I don't know how that works, but this LLC is not what
she takes money out of. And even then, this entire thing is solely
funded by Pierre Omidyar. They are very transparent about everything
to do with their foundation, right?
It's just their thing. It's their baby. It's the thing they do,
right?
So, Z comes in super hot, does something really stupid,
and yeah, we're going to have to watch him back away from it.
>> also taking dark My issue with her is that she lies
about
>> And that she makes fun of people that are also taking
dark money. Like I just God, she drives me insane.
>> Yeah, I guess I just don't I really just don't like
the term dark money. Um, if you're referring to like a particular
entity itself, then I think it's okay, but once you start like
going downstream of that, I think things get really stupid really
fast. So, like
>> If I'm funding somebody to go and do a thing, you know
what I believe in. You know what I'm telling them to do. Like
it really doesn't matter at that point like who's giving me money
per se. What matters is like I'm giving money to somebody else
and then these are the objectives that I would hope to achieve.
The idea that you would call that person funded by dark money
because you don't know who my funders are, that's just very weird
to me cuz you could just run that line down infinitely for anything.
It just yeah, it just seems really
Well, I I would just say if you're a political operative and
you're taking that money, you don't know who's funding you. There
is something to be said there, absolutely. And it's just not
it's literally just descriptive.
Now, once you get yeah, a couple links down the chain, something
like that kicks in if it's not political actors anymore. But
like Chorus is working directly with a dark money fund to get
people paid. I I do believe that's the case. They go into something
later. I'm I'm pretty sure that's the case. I'm pretty sure they
thanked 1634 being the funder of the incubator program. But in
any case, there's something to be said there. I would say Chorus
is still taking dark money. You could
And that's okay. Really really the issue here is not even that
they're taking dark money. That's like a concern. It's the lack
of disclosures. That's the big deal. You got a bunch of influencers
who are getting money to say things, who are going to like daily
messaging meetings and stuff like that, and they're not disclosing
that they're a part of the program, right? They're not disclosing
that they're in this program at all. Or they weren't. I still
believe the vast majority of them are not.
So, that's what I am concerned about. That's really I think that's
the main thrust of the article is that there's no disclosures,
and they're being prevented from disclosing, or they're being,
you the disclosures are like chilled by the contract language.
>> I mean, pretty much everything in politics is dark money.
>> Depending on, yeah, depending on how far back you want
to trace or whatever. >> individual candidate, right? But
like no or PACs, yeah.
Yeah, but most funding doesn't go through PACs or candidates.
It goes through IE programs.
Because there's no I'm right, so like
Yeah, so I mean, you have you have to abide by the individual
contribution
If you're going through a campaign, so >> a PAC, or a candidate,
yeah, but for the hybrid entities or the super PACs, these C4
C3 hybrids, you you don't have the same Well, you have no limits,
right? >> Yeah, there's no limit. So, that that's why they
want to But it's I like I don't know. I just If you really care
about this stuff, then why aren't you investigating Republicans?
Like she investigated like one Republican entity like 5 years
ago. That doesn't count. Like if you actually care about dark
money, that's what you would be doing.
>> You know, I mean, there's so much There's The thing
is is like obviously, I mean, there's some We need some form
of campaign finance reform, right? Like I think everybody can
agree on that. But we have to I mean, if we're going to have
like a serious conversation about that, then we have to have
We we have to be honest with where we're at. And she's just not
She's not being honest with where we're at. >> Yeah, because
nobody
>> I think she's being perfectly honest with where we're
at. I think it really has to do with lack of
I do think I don't think she's being like dishonest. I think
the thing that really [__] this up was Taylor had
this look at the article. She had this this like overall article
she'd built. And all it all it would have taken to take the teeth
out of this article completely is just a couple of comments from
Chorus.
If they had just commented on the story before publication, which
they were offered the opportunity to, they could have taken the
teeth out of the story
Right? They could have taken They could have entirely taken the
teeth out of this story. It wouldn't have been a big
That's all they had to do, right? They could have gone, "Oh,
actually our contract language was bad and we're going to fix
that." That's our bad.
That's literally all it take That's all it would take. >> actually
cares about these issues. They just weaponize them to go after
the people they don't like, right? That's why That's my big issue
with a lot of like finance-related talk is that the people just
don't have much information about the structures. They don't
know much about tax or entity formation or anything. And then
And then the yeah, they're they're very selective in terms of
>> Uh this is just a weird opinion to have when you had
to look up everything about this whole thing after the fact.
He goes 02 to Taylor Lorenz and only after the second time he
loses, he decides to then then the rest of the stream is just
researching
like like tax structures, how the media network is structured,
all of this stuff. That's such a weird comment.
>> of how they critique things and they're very sneaky
with the way that they approach it all and it just feels very
stupid, yeah. >> Did you ever get an answer out of her
as to why we never saw the damn contract?
>> Uh she she would just like vaguely allude to lawyers
or whatever, but that's yeah, I don't
>> She'd just vaguely allude to lawyers or whatever. Well,
actually she said there was something of a conflict there was
what she said specifically. She said there was a conflict there
as in she wasn't she wasn't certain that if she leaked the contract
that it wouldn't out the person, that there wouldn't be some
sort of special either watermarks or phraseology or something
about the the way the contract's set up, right? That gives away
it sort of uniquely labels it so that you could see who the person
was. That's what she was concerned about, right? And so, the
funny thing is is I believe Destiny was actually asked later
to just publish the contract.
What do you guys think he said?
>> I don't see that confidentiality thing in this unless
they're misreading the under definitions or whatever. I don't
know if these contracts are like actually uniquely different
per persons. I don't know risk like burning my
contact on this, but I see um >> Oh, so
the same reason he doesn't want to publish the full thing for
the same
>> We have So, there's a confidentiality clause. It lists
out definitions. Then it's also going to say to me about trade
Um I don't see that confidentiality
So, the clause he would be looking for is basically saying that
if you wish to disclose your the nature of your like funding
relationship, the nature of your relationship to Corus, I think
the the funding or the donators, then you need to ask us. I think
was specifically the language that they reported on.
Maybe that's not there. I don't know.
I don't know.
>> I don't know. It's annoying. It's annoying because there
weren't even any there there just there weren't very many quotes
in that article that were longer than like two words about the
contract itself. And she keeps saying they well, they were citing
to it, but her citation is like her opinion. Like generally,
I'm not aware of like how you I don't know what it means to >> Well,
I don't know that I I literally I
the nice thing about this is, you know, as much as I I don't
dislike Taylor
but I have had problems with her reporting in the past. And the
nice thing about this whole story, right? Is that we actually
don't have to rely on Taylor Lorenz's word at all. In any case,
Piero Media's word we can rely on and Wired's word we can rely
on. Right? We actually don't have to rely on Taylor Lorenz's
word at all.
How trustworthy she is, how much you could rely on her reporting,
how accurate her reporting is, how much she knows how to read
contracts, none of that stuff actually comes into play, right?
None of it.
Because she had people looking over her shoulder every step of
the way. If the article had actually been misrepresented, the
article then sorry if the article had misrepresented the contract,
sorry you said the article twice, then Chorus would have easily
been able to force Wired to issue a correction. Yeah, exactly.
Well, the other thing is is for the for the non-disclosure parts
the funny thing to me is that they didn't just have the contract
for that. They had like Zoom calls and like this, right? They
had other pieces of
that led them to believe that they were discouraged from disclosing.
It wasn't just the contract. >> Cite to something that
we can't read or that's not publicly available. Like I'm citing
to something that nobody has access to except for me, but the
citation is just her opinion on the thing. It's just very frustrating
to me. I don't know. >> I just I don't even get what the
criticism is because the thing is is like I mean I know a lot
of the content creators in Chorus, right? Because one of my friends
created Chorus.
>> Uh sorry, I was going to I was going to read this, but
I'm pretty sure this is a meme. >> Uh first of all, I don't
think that he's sneaky like that. I just like personally, right?
But like cuz he actually gives a [__] about this
stuff. He could make a lot more money doing other things. He
doesn't even get paid to do Chorus. Like that's just like a passion
project. The same thing is like National Ground Game is to me,
but um but like
>> What? What? It's Uh apparently National Ground Game
is a passion project. Did she not bill her own company for hours?
I'm pretty sure National Ground Game
Is it Soul Solutions, Soul Strategies, something like this? Whatever
Z's contracting company is, her her I'm pretty sure she pays
herself a salary out of that. You made NGG pack? She did make
NGG pack, yes, she did.
It's like her job. Yeah, it's not even that it's like wrong that
she bill herself.
Or that yeah, that she bill herself. It's not wrong. It's just
like
Is it just a passion project? You don't
Maybe she just, you know, takes her costs out.
You never know, maybe maybe. >> Let's just say that okay,
they actually they were getting talking points from the Democratic
Party. Like what is the issue? I don't even know what the issue
with that even is. Like Repub-
>> Wasn't that wasn't that the thing you said she was lying
about?
>> I Wasn't that That's literally what Z, by the way
I read that Z Z sees the problem, okay? So when I said that she
was lying, I got a whole bunch of pushback from people,
When she did her little thing here >> dark money queen
herself take a point >> The dark money queen herself >> lying
online. Now, the biggest issue with this article is that she
claimed that these content creators had to say specific talking
points in order to get paid that were passed down from the Democratic
Party.
>> Now, when I when I heard that, my uh the reason I thought
she was lying was because
to me, what she's trying to say
is they were given like actual things to basically read off.
Like those that this you're being dictated to, this is what you're
going to read, this is what you're going to talk about today,
right?
And I'm like, okay, that's not the way it works, and you're just
lying about what it is. But if she's just saying what is already
known is that these people are going to align with the values,
the the policy agenda of Course, and that they are literally
course was literally built to get Democrat messaging out. Well,
then yeah, that's that's not even just prove proven by the article.
It's proven by like Brian Tyler Cohen's
So, how is she how is that the biggest problem? That's literally
what's
It's funny that she switched up from here and she's like, well,
even if that was happening,
which it totally is. Sorry, totally is that they're being like
basically given messaging ways to message things, right?
Which by the way, I don't necessarily have a problem with. It's
fine. Just disclose it.
Like she basically said that's they were it was like a quid pro
quo was what Taylor was reporting. And I don't think Taylor was
reporting that at all. Some people pointed to the title of the
article. It's like I understand there's maybe an implication
in the title of the article. I don't think it's that strong an
implication at all. And it's categorically disproven by the actual
content of the article.
So, like even if there was an implication in the title,
it's not
like it's not actioned on in the article at all.
It's it's like disproven in the article. Nobody no not once does
it say you have to cover these explicit Democrat talking >> I
mean, I can understand the frustrating part about it, but the
thing is is what you would have to push for is a reform on how
they're legally allowed to operate. Because like I can understand
being annoyed. If I see 10 different creators giving a talking
point that feels good, I would view that a lot differently if
I knew the funding for that was all coming from a single source.
I would view that differently. And I think it's worth knowing
about. But like I don't know why you would attack an >> Oh,
like the exact thing we all think.
>> individual entity that's using this. Like everybody
should be doing that given that it's currently legal. If you
want to change it, then change the laws around it.
>> I agree.
agree. I mean, I just >> But the thing is is what you would
have to push for is a reform on how they're legally allowed to
operate. Because like I can understand being annoyed. If I see
10 different creators giving a talking point that feels good,
I would view that a lot differently if I knew the funding for
that was all coming from a single source. I would view that differently.
And I think that's worth knowing about. But like, I don't know
why you would attack an individual entity that's using this.
Like everybody should be doing that given that it's currently
legal. If you want to change it >> Why wait? Is he advocating
for like um deception here?
Is he literally advocating like he thinks deception is the better
strategy?
Cuz you could look at it that way. I think unchecked deception
is probably the better strategy. The issue is then if you decide
for the deception strategy and then you get caught well then
you're kind of hooped, right? Then you look totally disingenuous.
You look totally fake. And I think when these people have these
these disclosure agreements these these agreements that basically
limit or try to chill them disclosing that they're being paid
by this company
I do think things get very sketchy then. Right? If it was just
people deciding on their own, but it
I've not seen it disputed yet. I've not seen it disputed by Corus
that there is language in the contracts that basically tried
to chill
looking to disclose that they're being paid by Corus, right?
Or 1630 whatever the [__]
That was definitely there. So when you get caught with this stuff
if you are trying to do secrecy, it looks bad. And you have to
accept that it looks bad and you can't get ass mad about it looking
bad. You can't go well, we're Democrats so you should look the
other way. That's pretty disingenuous, man. That's I don't think
that's how that works. >> You haven't changed the laws
around it.
>> I agree. >> I 100% agree. I mean I just I think
>> If you If you want me to believe you're going to take
down the GOP, please don't get defeated by Taylor Lorenz. We
need him to defeat Trump. Loses to Taylor Lorenz twice. Well
>> You know like we should just be like I I don't I just
don't understand why anybody is against us like combating red
pill pipeline information or bad Republican information. >> Why
does she do red pill pipeline and alt-right pipeline? In this
video she does or sorry, where's the Twitter? In this she says
alt-right pipeline in this >> that's been let go from every
single
because of how unserious she is. >> But she was relevant
for a very small blip of time about 6 months ago when she released
a ridiculous article in The Wire where she talked about the 1630
fund that's funding a group called Chorus. Chorus is a group
of political influencers on the left that is trying to fight
the alt-right pipeline online. Now the big
They're trying to fight the alt-right pipeline online.
Okay? It's like
a very feminine Arnold Schwarzenegger or something. I don't know
how to describe it. Anyway,
I don't know, she just uses buzzwords a lot. It's like very What
kind of accent is that? I think she's been living in America
for a very long time, but she came from Australia. You hear the
nowrs in there a lot. Yeah. You get the nowrs in there a lot.
>> Like we're already so so far behind in this, right?
Like there's so many studies out there that shows that we're
like like Republicans are pushing out like whatever it is, like
50 times more like content than us every day. So like what I
I just don't get the issue of having Democratic
uh you know, influencers coordinating together. I I just don't
know what what the issue with that would be. >> Yeah. I
mean broadly I don't really think she's too supportive of the
Democratic Party.
You should go national.
So I don't think >> What made you think that? Was it the
retweeting of Hasan calling you a pedo >> Um well, that
could just be a personal hatred for me, right? >> I don't
know. What did you think that >> What did I just miss here?
>> I mean broadly I don't really think she's too supportive
of the Democratic
>> That him with his Discord notifications on with the
[__]
>> You should go national.
>> So I don't think >> What what think that? Was
it the retweeting of Hasan calling you a pedo >> Um well,
that >> Oh, Hasan calling you a pedo, I see. Why does she
Why does she I does she not understand like probably just don't
bring that up, especially don't bring that up on
Like how does how dude This is the thing is like bro, these are
your guys.
I would be so annoyed if I had something like that and my my
like guys come on stream and they're like, "Hey, were you like
upset that this person called you a It's like Bro, come on.
We're not trying to advertise.
Like by the way, even if it's untrue and in Destiny's case, in
a technical sense, untrue, okay? In a technical sense. Bro, it
just sounds bad, right? It's just dude, what are you doing?
I'll be honest, it looks bad when you got food shops around,
too. But hey. >> It could just be a personal hatred for
me, right? >> I don't know. I feel like there's
Uh she has a lot of personal hatred for me, too. Don't worry.
She's been tweeting at me 100 times in the last 24 hours, so.
Oh, yeah. >> keeps playing the same thing. She just >> She
loves the internet. She spends a lot of time on the internet.
>> Yeah, clearly. Seriously.
Well
>> Oh, we could definitely throw stones there, guys. Destiny
ZB, everyone in the chat, we can throw stones. Guys, these people
are so online. These people are so Aren't Isn't it embarrassing?
Don't these people have real lives? Don't any Don't any of these
people have real lives, guys? Anytime you see Destiny anywhere
out in public, he's literally glued to his phone. Don't these
people have These people are so online. Don't they have real
lives? >> Well, anyway, that was that was a painful thing
to watch. Thanks for putting us through through all that. Appreciate
it.
Um pretty good. >> So, yeah, ASU,
everybody come.
Does anybody have questions about the chapters or about the events
or
>> Wow. Okay, I think that's the end of this, I think.
I think that's the end of this. I think I can go to the next
time stamp, yeah. Pretty sure. Pretty sure. Pretty sure. Pretty
sure.
Let's go to this time stamp right here.
>> Okay, I I hear you now.
Now, Destiny woo.
Missed out on a little bit of research here, but Destiny basically
I think he he does some research for a little bit and then eventually
Follery calls into the stream, okay? And if you guys missed it
yesterday, Tom was in the chat and he was none too pleased with
Destiny, okay?
None too pleased.
He went on a stream, he talked about it. He his whole title thumbnail
was Destiny flopped in this debate. Destiny sucked in this debate.
And so now Tom Follery showed up, he's going to educate
and
All right, so take it away, Tom. >> Okay. What the last
person said is really important. The The 1630 is just a fiscal
sponsor. >> that. Where is that show? Where is that listed
at?
>> Uh I don't know where it's listed at. >> Okay,
then I don't care about that. Go on to the next thing. >> Brian
Tyler Cohen says it in his video. >> And there's also lawyers
for people who >> Go on to the next thing. Go on to the
next thing. What's the next point? I need I just want I need
it I just need to see it somewhere. >> I don't Yeah, so
if you go to if you go to 1630's website, they talk about the
fact that that is the role that they play. Just go to the about
us and it explains that they're a fiscal sponsor and that they
just help smaller organizations start up, but that they don't
pay them. They don't pay like Course. They don't pay Course members.
That's not what they do. So, they they're not like the way that
Taylor makes it sound like they fund them. They don't fund them.
The it's just a fiscal >> this is true.
I actually don't think this is true. And now I am a little curious.
Is there not an an announcement Is there not an announcement
for the incubator
So, Course
incubator
program.
Now, I could have sworn
basically sponsored by the 1630 Fund.
When you say fiscal sponsorship, that means monetary sponsorship.
I believe that means that they are literally paying for it. I
don't think it just means what Tom is saying, but maybe I'm wrong
on that. Maybe I'm just Maybe it it doesn't sound like that.
I I Yeah, I don't
I don't know. >> There's um >> way Tom explains this
seems a little confusing to me, but I maybe I just, you know,
wasn't paying enough attention. I was driving. >> How do
we know that the 1630 Fund has given money or has funded
um Chorus?
>> They haven't Again, they don't fund >> Or that
they're that they're a fiscal sponsor of Chorus.
>> Yeah, um okay. So, I don't I don't know that there's
anything until Chorus >> So, I think the way this works
is basically like they come There's a
And essentially what happens is
1630 puts some money aside for this proposal for these incubator
like the class of incubator
Chorusites or whatever you want to call them, okay, influencers.
And I think they'd set aside that money and they say, "Okay,
we're going to pay them this stipend monthly. We'll set it all
up. They'll register with us." And it will it'll happen through
Chorus and Chorus will be like the people who are
who are running the program kind of, but I do believe that it's
like on their paychecks it would be from the 1630 Fund. I think.
>> Chorus actually like files their 990s,
which they might even file a 990PF, but they they haven't filed
anything yet. So, there's not really a way for us to look at
it on like actual tax filings. >> Okay. What was the name
of Taylor Lorenz's article? >> Dark money >> Dark
money group secretly funding. Okay. >> Yeah. I think her
>> He's just looking for a way to like go, "She got this
wrong. She's wrong."
Why Why are you waiting till after you've lost two debates to
go and be like, "Well, now I'm going to go try to figure out
where she's wrong.
But I Is this not the wrong time? Is this Is this the time you're
supposed to be looking at? I thought you were supposed to look
that stuff up before you do the debate.
Am I Am I misunderstanding how debates are supposed to work?
This is like the Fuentes debate on Israel on like basically Israel's
influence on Middle Eastern foreign policy where Destiny debated
Fuentes, got his ass ripped apart, and then started like learning
[__] about Israel
That's like That's what this is. >> Her evidence in her
article was that because 1630 is on the paychecks that that to
her meant that they were funding Chorus, but that just means
that they're the fiscal sponsor. >> I mean, no. October
7th was the spark for like the long-term research thing. But
he had to go look some stuff up on basically Middle Eastern foreign
policy and [__] because he basically like didn't
off the top of his head know when Israel was founded.
Like he
This guy was born in like the 1930s,
and they were talking about like why who this guy was loyal to.
And I believe Destiny was like, "Well, wasn't this guy born in
Israel?
This guy was born in What What Of course he'd have like some
loyalty to Israel. Wasn't he born there? He's born in like the
'30s.
Like, dude, are you
I remember groaning so [__] hard when I heard that.
It was like I It was later in the debate, too, and I'm just like,
"Bro, are you [__] kidding me? Are you [__]
serious right now?"
>> And then I also sent you the
uh 1630 page where they just talk about like being a fiscal sponsor
for
for people, but it pretty much means that they like Chorus pays
1630, not that 1630 funds Chorus. It's Chorus pays 1630
to do their admin work, and that gives six That gives Chorus
1630's 501c4
um like umbrella
um category. So that now Chorus can be filed as a file
because 1630 is fiscally sponsoring >> What does that mean?
So, does 16
30 provide like like just services for free basically or
What does it mean to fiscally sponsor >> much not for free.
Like so Cor- >> Okay, so there's a fiscal sponsorship of
the program? Hold on.
Let me see here. National Chorus. I'm looking for like the um
We have like when Chorus did their
We have the like incubator thing?
Cuz I could have sworn they talked about this with the 1630 fund,
but now it's all like gone.
>> Chorus like >> 1630 will take a cut of things.
So, like if I want to donate to Chorus >> I do not >> I
do not believe it was just this fiscal sponsorship thing. Project
sources funding. I do not believe the that Chorus sourced all
the funding for this. I never got that impression.
I I never got that impression once, and it feels like it would
have been something immediately corrected by
Like that was never corrected. >> I go and I donate, but
it goes through 1630.
So, that the it's going through a 501c4,
and then they give the money to Chorus. Chorus pays them to do
this like admin work. Then 1630 also gives them >> So,
I I understand what Tom's saying. Basically, that like when you
fiscally sponsor something, they it could be it could get like
it could take donations as a 501c4.
Once you could do that, you get like an ActBlue account, you
take all your donations, and then you could start running your
own programs, right? Now, did they get enough in donations to
run like how long was the first incubator program, and how many
creators was it?
Like did this did they get enough in donations to do that? Cuz
I could have sworn 1630 did fund them did fund the program the
incubator program specifically.
But maybe not. Maybe they didn't take any money at all. I But
then why didn't they correct that part of the article? Now, it's
not money laundering. It's It's It's not money laundering any
more than traditional 501(c)(4)s are money laundering, right?
It's not that. But it just feels so weird to me that they wouldn't
have corrected this.
>> And like um they get their legal advice
uh other things like that, but then when
when Corus wants to pay all the content creators who are part
of Corus, then 1630 pays those creators. So again, all of it
ends up going through 1630 so that they get the 501(c)(4) status.
>> Why do you say that? So they get the 501(c)(4) status.
How can I connect that for me?
>> That's what a fiscal sponsor is. Like a fiscal sponsor
is like a somebody who does the admin work for you so that you're
able to get the 501(c)(4) status. So like all of it goes through
>> that Why would you get >> I'm guessing So I'm
guessing this is like you get an ActBlue account. I don't know
if they say it here. I'm guessing like you get signed up for
an ActBlue
with a 501(c)(4) designation under 1630,
and then the donations will flow into 1630,
and then 1630 basically just says we're going to pay people out
for you out of these donations that are flowing >> Get
the 501(c)(4). What does that mean? What What do you mean by
Just connect
>> Um I don't I don't understand like the exact legal aspect
of it. Um but the That's just what a fiscal sponsor is. So like
I I sent you the the page on 1630 that kind of explains like
what they do as a fiscal sponsor. >> Mr. Flurry, yes. >> helps
other organizations get their 501(c)(4) status.
>> But then the entire dark money angle of this goes away
entirely.
Like it's entirely gone.
Which is a big part of the article. And Maybe I have to rewatch
Brian Tyler Cohen, but I didn't think he said like, "Oh, we don't
get a lick of money. We don't get any money at all from 1630."
I don't think he said that. And I don't think that was implied
in their announcement either, cuz I feel like I looked at their
original announcement that basically said we're we're like proud
to partner with, you know, 1630 on this. They're They're going
to fund this first incubator program.
I could have sworn, man. What's he trying to process right now?
Bro, I told you my brain wasn't working before this. I don't
know what he's trying to process. You guys understand what they're
saying, right? Basically, you can you can function as like somebody
else's like
you know, legal buddy. They could get an ActBlue account, they
could take donations, and then they can like
disperse those donations, they can actually fund things for you.
You do like a partnership with them, and then you're running
your your [__] right
Right? So, the project sources funding. So, you source the funding,
you get like an ActBlue account, or you put your own money in,
and then 1630, that money is no is now tax exempt.
Right? You put that money in, that money is going to that organization,
it's tax exempt, it can be paid out. Okay?
1630 Fund provides support to help the project scale and quickly
quickly and efficiently. So, probably guidance on how to like
yeah, set up an ActBlue account, on everything you need to do
to run like an
political action committee, or whatever the [__]
you want to call it, whatever
some philanthropic venture, whatever the [__] okay?
Project remains part of 1630 Fund, becomes independent, or ends.
Okay. >> Yeah, that was pretty much it. Like they they
don't fund chorus.
Wait, that's kind of a big deal then. Wait, is that true? So
>> This would be This would be another big deal, Canadian
callers. They would probably file all the paperwork. Cuz that
would be a big deal is like, you know, Brian Tyler Cohen, let's
say he's running it on his own. He's an influencer, he doesn't
know [__] about accounting. Maybe he's not a big
influencer, maybe he needs somebody to help him like figure out
exactly how to file everything to comply with all of the FEC
regulations.
This means that it's a massive deal. >> So, this means
that because it's saying here, so like other fiscal sponsors,
the 1630 Fund is not the original source of funding for the projects
it incubates. When a foundation or funder makes a donation to
support a project, the fiscal sponsor receives the donation on
behalf of the project. 1630 fund follows all local, state, and
federal law with respect to the disclosure. >> How. Now,
here's the thing.
Did some
You know what this has to be?
The reality is, if you knew who it was who was funding it, or
if if the person actually funding it wanted to be
I'm guessing they could. The reality is, I think they don't want
to disclose it. They don't want you to know who is funding it.
It's probably I wouldn't be shocked if it was Omidyar himself,
to be honest with you. Since he's involved with all of this [__]
And I wouldn't be shocked, okay?
But there's a different funder, and I don't think it's small
donations. So there is somebody else funding this, right? That's
what I'm taking away now, is that it might not have been 1630,
but it it wasn't worth clearing up because it's still dark money.
It's still like somebody donated to the 501c4.
And I'm guessing if we looked at their filings for this year,
you'd see somebody donating to 1630 on behalf like earmarked
for
this stuff, earmarked for Chorus without their name or any identity
attached to it. I'm guessing that's what it is, right? That seems
most likely cuz otherwise they go, "No, no, no, we don't get
any money for We don't have dark money. We're like all small
donations. We We We source the funding ourselves."
No, it's it's still dark money going into this thing, and
Not that I have a problem with that >> of individual
So, the money So, when I go to donate basically then So, if I
want to donate to Chorus,
What do they have a donation thing, right? The on the front.
Donate. They do. Okay. So, if I want to donate >> Wouldn't
it all come out in their taxes? Not No, no, no, the
the 990 forms or whatever that usually disclose names in a 501c3.
I think in a 501c4 you don't have to disclose the names at all.
Their names, addresses, that stuff's all censored. Oh, interesting.
If it was small enough, I guess I guess if it was small enough,
I wouldn't really consider it dark money, but then realistically,
somebody could structure things in such a way that they look
like small donors, right? Donating with different names, different
addresses, and still be a big donor. So, I guess you could still
consider it dark money if it's, you know, nothing's disclosed.
This money is going to flow through
um the 1630 fund. >> Yeah. This is a great question, Latisha's
Gamer. I didn't I didn't I was unaware of this strategy. Sometimes
I don't take debates cuz I'm not aware of the topic. Apparently,
you're supposed to take the debate, get your ass blown up by
some amateur, and then start studying after.
Bonus points if you could do that twice before actually doing
the studying. >> And then they will allocate that back
to Chorus, and then they'll take some percentage here for basically
payment
Okay. Interesting. Um interesting. Oh, jeez. Okay, I get that.
Yeah, so so Taylor's entire article is about the fact that 1630
fund >> Moody Morgan, that's the definition of
dark money, yes. That only the IRS knows. That is literally the
definition, yes, if it's not disclosed publicly. Um for political
contributions in a way that um Yeah, yeah.
That's like that's what
all of this stuff is about. >> Uh Chorus, but they and
she even says in your conversation over and over that she doesn't
call Chorus a dark money group, that Chorus is not dark money,
that only 1630 is dark money, and that all the content creators,
even though they did disclose that they work for Chorus, and
that they're getting paid by Chorus, the problem is they didn't
disclose that they're getting paid by 1630, but they're not getting
paid by 1630. They're not funded by 1630.
I understand. Why um So, wait, do you What is her definition
of dark money, do you know?
>> It's a 501c4 some group that doesn't disclose where
their money comes from that engages in political action. >> Okay,
can you explain to me because it looks like 501c4s all have to
print like a publicly accessible form 990 with a schedule B attached.
So, but you don't have to include the names or the addresses
of people that donate, but you do have to include donations.
Like contributions. >> Yeah, so who you donate to, but
not who donates to you. >> Well, what what I don't understand
that because it feels like Can you give me an example of an organization
like because it feels like 501c4s all have to file 990s with
attached schedule Bs. >> Yeah, they they have to report
it to the IRS. They just >> But they're publicly viewable
those schedule Bs. That's my understanding so
>> The schedule Bs are the things that show >> names
and addresses were there. >> contributing money to you.
Well, so like the schedule Bs for these 501c4s like I'm going
to give you the 16/30 fund. I can see the people who have contributed
to them on their schedule B, but it doesn't have the name, address,
and
>> So, you can't see the people?
Is this guy good?
What is
this is rough. This is why I will never like program on stream.
Okay, I would do better than this programming. Whatever this
is, I would do better than this. But like
bro, watching somebody's thought process on stream sometimes
is rough.
Guys, it's like not Why is it even considered like dark money?
I can see all the donations.
I can see I can see all the donations, guys. Why is it even considered
dark >> Zip code. So, they can redact that part.
>> Just like uh with you remember when progressive victory
accidentally doxxed everybody because they accidentally put all
that information in there, but it wasn't supposed >> Uh
anonymous, thank you very much for the five gifted subs. Appreciate
it, dude. Appreciate it. >> to be on the public form. It
was only supposed to be on the IRS form. >> Gotcha. Okay,
yeah.
Wait, so is this really this is the dark So, it's Was it just
this then? So, it's dark money because we just don't know the
names of the people that contribute
to a 501c4? That's it? And it can you can be an
Bro, this is worse than I remember already. I I feel like I was
listening. I just was driving. I didn't realize how stupid this
sounded. Is it really just that we we literally don't know who
these people are? That's why it's dark money? Is that why it's
it's dark money cuz we don't know who they are?
>> I mean, okay. >> Oh, it's pretty. >> Which
is why she kept saying that Omidyar isn't dark money because
we know that uh Pierre Omidyar and his wife Pam Omidyar are the
only contributors to
Democracy Fund Voice.
Are we going to need some people to tell Tom that he has to produce
all documentation
of every single flow of cash to that LLC or else he is lying?
Okay, he doesn't know.
>> It's like >> Leave alone the fact that obviously
those people are you rich and they would never want somebody
else involved in their LLC and their foundation.
Leave alone all those things, okay? >> Yes, which is who
she gets her stipend >> Um I'll look I'll check that out
next, but I don't know if I understand
that yet because that what her organization is, none of those
filings are public at all, right?
>> So that that organization, Democracy Fund Voice, those
are not public They do file 990s and 990-PFs,
but they get their money from Democracy Fund. So Democracy Fund
donates to Democracy Fund Voice. Democracy Fund
>> Well, here I'll wait wait wait. Hold on. Hold on. Before
I get buried in that, I'll Okay, I'll get to that. Let me I'll
do that in I'll probably get to that in like 5 minutes, okay?
>> Will you get to that?
>> Okay, love you. Be careful.
>> I legitimately think that Destiny just ushered Tom out
because Tom was kind of like totally mogging him.
Is that why Destiny ushered Tom out?
Like I actually
I swear Tom was giving him good information and he was like not
happy that that's kind of rough.
>> Tom was
Tom was giving him good information. He's going to write that
down for later guys. We'll we'll keep an eye on that. He's going
to write that one down for later. Okay, so the 1630 fund works
as a
they work as a fiscal sponsor for chorus. Did he even write down
the voice
Which everybody said wrote. He didn't he didn't even write down
That's actually like important. What the
That's that's where Taylor Lorenz is paid from. That's like literally
your whole point about dark money would be sourced out of that.
Piece of Taylor Lorenz wrote yesterday for Wired. An initiative
aimed at boosting Democrats online offers influencers up to $8,000
a month to push the party line. All they have to do is keep it
secret and agree to restrictions on their content.
Literally nothing in the statement is true. The article is about
chorus which is a nonprofit that I helped found to build up a
creator ecosystem which everybody says they want but few are
doing. Dude, it's so funny listening to Brian Tyler Cohen. Like
when you'd ask these people like okay, cuz he basically argues
that it's like a way to teach people how to be influencers. And
then it's like well what do you do? It's like well we teach them
how to do lighting.
It's like okay.
What else do you do? The cope about like we're teaching people
how to be influencers is so [__] funny man. And they're
like try to make it out like that's a huge part of what they're
doing and not like the daily messaging check-ins and all of this
other [__] So here's what chorus is. It is a scholarship
program to teach creators how to grow their accounts, foster
engagement, launch their own shows, and become profitable on
their own. It's an incubator program to build the pro-democracy
ecosystem. Influencers and creators have never been more important
when it comes to how Americans are consuming their news. The
right has been doing this for years and the left needs to catch
up. That's why we're doing this with Chorus. So, let's talk about
what Chorus is and what it's not. Chorus does not pay creators
for content, does not tell them what to say, it does not control
who they talk to or work with, and there is abs- >> So,
this is like the same line as Progressive Victory,
Which is
I understand that
it For Progressive Victory, I think it's hard to argue that they
weren't just throwing money away, right?
It does get hard to argue.
I'm okay with this argument. So long as you get people to disclose,
or so long as people do disclose themselves.
Right? I'm okay with this. Like, hey, if you want to disclose
this and and take the money, it's whatever. All right, it's whatever.
I think when you get into not disclosing, that gets concerning
to me, right? And people will argue, "Well, I just do the same
content anyway." It's like, okay, but like, let's say Brian Tyler
Cohen gets caught texting of like 14-year-old boys.
Okay? And now you've not disclosed this, and you have a relationship
with him, and he's like he's basically put some [__]
out in private to you or to people around you that sort of says
this isn't true. Like, now you have a total conflict here. And
what are you going to do if you like sweep for him cuz you know
that private information, and then it comes out later that one,
he was lying, and two, you were getting paid.
You've totally eviscerated your credibility, right?
Like, there's there's just so many scenarios you could come up
with that your credibility suffers,
you if you aren't disclosing. I think you you should disclose.
You should always be looking to disclose this kind of thing.
Not disclosing it it just seems like it's I don't know. It's
[__] up for the creators. And that's I think one
of the major criticisms of the article is that it seems like
they were trying to chill those disclosures. They were saying,
"You have to message us if you you have to talk to us if you
want want that you're being funded by us." >> Absolutely
nothing in the contract that could even be reasonably interpreted
to say that we do. Period. Full stop. I don't know a single creator
who would willfully sign up for a program that would tell them
what they can or can't say. That's not what >> KFCan 6
What do you think that guy got banned for? Hold on. What do we
think that guy got banned for? What do you think the last thing
he said was? KFCan 6. If Destiny ever did research, he wouldn't
have been destroyed in yesterday's debate. Taylor really embarrassed
Destiny yesterday. This is what happens when you're when you
aren't a real journalist like Taylor.
good times.
IP ban that guy immediately. Get him the [__] out
of here.
That's some funny stuff, man. >> what this program is.
We pay people to show up to workshops and technical trainings
to optimize their content online. For example, we've got trainings
on how to package content for YouTube, trainings on how to optimize
audience retention for us. >> No, he was banned for the
mutant carrying him comments?
What was that?
Oh, is that when this was? It was the mutant carrying him comment?
Okay.
It wasn't this one. He got unbanned for this one or something?
Maybe. I actually can't tell.
I don't know when this was.
I feel like you guys are joking, but Oh, you guys are joking.
Okay. Okay. Got it. >> Got it. Got it. >> LLC. Again,
there are zero restrictions on their content. And by the way,
the program works. In just two months, our cohort has added a
combined 6 million followers. That's not including me and seen
their views and engagement grow. That is the point of the program,
to teach creators how to be effective with whatever messages
they want to promote. And with regard to keeping it a secret,
there is a standard confidentiality clause in the contract to
protect the privacy of the creators. On the literal first day
of the program, it was made clear to all of the creators in our
kickoff session that they were absolutely free to talk about
Chorus and we immediately followed up to confirm that in writing.
Creators >> Hold on. talk about Chorus. So, again, very
possibly like concerning wording here, right? Were they free
to talk about Chorus and the fact that they're partnered with
Chorus? Were they free to talk about the fact that they were
getting funded? Which one is it? Cuz the concern here is that
they're not free to talk about getting funded. >> was about
Chorus. They've got donation links to Chorus in their bios. I
myself have made videos that were posted all over the internet
about Chorus that reached hundreds of thousands of people. It
is not a secret and it never was. There's the implication in
the article that this is some arm of the DNC or the Democratic
Party. We have literally nothing to do with the DNC. I spent
>> Oh, this is such a blatant lie from
That's a little embarrassing in retrospect, okay?
And surely these people will be fair and they'll point out that
Brian was clearly lying here, right? Like clearly and obviously
lying. We have nothing to do with the DNC.
Brother, you were going around to all these influencers and saying,
"We need to get everybody on board with Democrat messaging."
Like we went to a Monday like we went to a morning meeting. We
need to be aligned on messaging. I'm going to make Chorus to
answer to to figure this out to get it get us on track here,
okay?
>> And zero minutes of my day thinking about the DNC. The
creators do not tow any party line. How could we? There isn't
a party line. Creators are absolutely allowed to speak out against
the Democrats and in fact, plenty do. And frankly, Chorus creators
should and do criticize Democrats when they suck and quite often,
they do suck. I've seen posts saying that uh this is APAC funded
which couldn't be further from the truth. I'd venture to guess
that most Chorus creators, myself included on both YouTube and
Substack, have spoken out against the >> All right. Just
Uh it's just funny. >> atrocities in Gaza. [clears throat]
>> Just funny. >> Loren says that the 1630 Fund is,
quote, "a powerful liberal dark money group." 1630 Fund is our
fiscal sponsor. One of the largest documented donors to 1630
fund is the same person funding a meteor's reporters and residence
program, which Taylor Lorenz herself is a part of. And guess
what her monthly stipend is? $8,000 per month. So, she's criticizing
an en- -tity that is funded by someone that she is currently
taking >> Why doesn't he talk about what the
Hold on. Fiscal sponsor thing means. I don't know why he wouldn't
say that. >> Oh, why did you pause there? Oh, there's no
way >> I don't know why he wouldn't say what explain what
a fiscal sponsor is. That's pretty That's pretty
>> He's crit- She's criticizing an entity
that is funded by the guy funding her. Now, is she criticizing
Course She's criticizing both Course and 1630. Is he giving away
that the actual funder of Course was possibly Pierre Omidyar?
>> Huge to not explain that. Because my I think my assumption
even until right now was that the 1630 fund contribute contributed
actually I thought all of it to Course. >> He said the
line he doesn't trust Wait, where did he say that? How far back,
Ryle? I might have I might have missed Where does he say he doesn't
trust Tom on this?
Where did he impugn the intellectual rigor of Tomfoolery?
>> Why doesn't he talk about what the fiscal sponsor thing
means? I don't know why he wouldn't say that. And I don't know
if I trust Tom.
>> I don't know if I trust Tom. What the
Tom's the only reason you have any idea about this. What do you
mean I don't know if I trust Tom?
I'll actually technically I thought the same thing. I don't know
if I trust Tom.
>> Wait, Tom's in chat.
In Destiny's first convo with Taylor, she kept saying my article
never said they work for the DNC, but she retweeted tons of leftists
who said her article said that said it. LOL.
Hmm, how do we parse that? So, it is affiliated with the DNC.
It is like about Democrat messaging. It's about making sure,
you know, the whole thing when they did the pitch originally
was the DNC like doesn't know how to get the its message out.
We need to fix that. We need to fill the gaps here.
So, I don't doubt that she would have retweeted those things.
There is something to be said, I think she got some way different
opinions than what's in the article, right? What she was allowed
to write. Yeah, I think she's got some opinions that this is
like funded by Israel that or sorry, that this was like pro-Israel
in general, that they didn't want to fund as many like pro-Palestinian
people. I think she she had a lot of her own opinions that she
kept out of the article. >> I don't know why he wouldn't
say what explain what a fiscal sponsor is. It's pretty that's
pretty huge to not explain
Because my I think my assumption even until right now was that
the 1630 fund contribute contributed actually I thought all of
it to Chorus. I think Taylor even said that two days ago when
we were chatting. Maybe he talks about it in a second, I don't
know. >> money from. I guess it's okay when Taylor Lorenz
gets paid, but no one else. The monthly stipend that we offer
is so that creators can do this work full-time. We've had numerous
creators in the cohort quit their job so that they can focus
on creating content full-time. That is what we want. I'm really
proud that we can give >> Is that he's going to say this
himself and not elaborate? Well, maybe he should for clips or
something, but they did just go over it in the in the um >> creators
that security for as long as they're in the program. We want
people to create pro-democracy content full-time. And we want
to make sure that they can afford to pay their rent and their
bills while doing it. If I could have cohorts with a thousand
people in it so that everybody could be part of the program,
I would. For everybody saying they would like to be part of the
next cohort, we would love for you to apply. That's our whole
goal, is to build up an army of pro-democracy content creators.
>> So, I also he says it they're the fiscal sponsor. I
got to imagine that fiscal sponsorship, even though it doesn't
1630 funding, I feel like 1630 funded
I feel like he would have absolutely made sure to hammer home
cuz that that kind of sinks Taylor in some ways. If 1630's not
funding this at all, that does kind of sink Taylor in some ways.
It makes her look really bad. I don't know why he wouldn't include
it. It just doesn't make any sense, right? >> Who can speak
authentically about the issues that they care about and be able
to do it as effectively as possible? I can note that while I
started this program, I have never and will never get paid. I
do this 100% as a volunteer. I've never earned a dime from Crooked
Media and I never will. I want every dollar that we raise to
go to creators so that they can do this important work without
spending 8 hours a day working at some different job. I've been
saying for years that the left needs to build up its creator
space. That has never been more true than it is right now. Influencers
and creators have never been more important when it comes to
how Americans are consuming their news. The left is a decade
behind right now. We desperately need incubators teaching and
amplifying new content creators and not just Crooked Media by
the way. There are other programs in this space doing the same
thing. I want all of them to succeed. We need all of them to
succeed. There are people like Taylor Lorenz who are desperate
to tear the left apart and in fact it becomes clear who her help
is when you hear stuff like this. Genuinely, I kind of liked
Taylor Lorenz because I know that she actually believes what
I said. >> Dude, it's actually such the way Brian Tyler
Cohen just did this like
This is such bull bro. By the way, tell What's one time Candace
Owens said something nice about Taylor Lorenz? That's like okay.
Okay.
What the [__] is this? >> Okay. So yeah, I
uh generally don't align myself with friends of Tucker Carlson
and Candace Owens. I continue to believe that the left needs
massive investments into the independent media space. I'm really
proud of the program that we built. I'm really proud that we've
allowed creators to do this work full-time. I'm really proud
of the independence that they have to say whatever they want
to say in whatever way they want to say it. I'm really proud
that our creators are seeing their channels and their pages grow.
My goal is to see an army emerge from the left to take on what's
happening on the right. Taylor Lorenz and Republicans >> Okay.
Why What a missed opportunity. I don't think I've ever heard
this explanation before.
It's funny that we literally don't have
like an actual We don't have a response on that. We don't have
a like a resolution on this. I don't know if they get funded
by 1630 or not. I assume they have to be. >> I'm thinking
about fiscal sponsorship, purpose and politics. Fiscal >> suspicion
is that people like Reid Hoffman and possibly Larry Ellison are
involved in funding this. Why do you say Larry Ellison?
Cuomo did 9/11.
I've seen I've seen you around Cuomo did 9/11. I've seen you
around.
Why do you Why do you feel like Larry Ellison was involved? >> Fiscal
sponsorship is an arrangement through which a group that doesn't
have its own tax-exempt status from the IRS. It offers several
advantages for smaller or newer organizations allowing them to
pursue their tax-exempt and mission in ways they might not otherwise
be able to. At the same time, there are virtually no public disclosure
requirements for fiscal sponsorships.
Uh particularly with respect to those projects that are active
on political or public policy issues. Fiscal sponsorships
uh fiscal spon- >> the fart sound. You guys
come on. I don't have that soundboard. I I didn't put that on
my soundboard anyway, okay? I could have it, but it's uh
Listen, it's not appropriate. >> could be considered a
form of dark money. Fiscal sponsorship reform should initially
focus on enhancing transparency through the involved updates
to the IRS Form 990. When he says
particularly with respect Okay, at the time there were virtually
no public disclosure requirements for fiscal sponsorship. What
does that mean? Cuz it don't they aren't there? What are the
>> Yeah, I'm I'll be honest, I don't really care for the
research part of this.
Personally, personally
uh okay, hold on. Next timestamp. >> So, there's a confidentiality
clause. It >> Hold on. Did I not get I might have missed
this. >> I don't know if these contracts are like actually
uniquely different per persons. I don't want to >> Oh,
hold on. I I went to the wrong
Wait, is this the right timestamp? Give me a second.
Cuz this is the most interesting part of the stream, I think.
He's reading.
He gets given somebody's chorus sponsor like contract, sorry.
Not sponsorship. He gets given the contract. He literally gets
given the contract. Shouldn't he be able to like obviously
point out everything wrong with the
Destiny has the contract. Destiny has one of the chorus contracts
right now.
>> I don't see that confidentiality thing in this unless
they're misreading the under definitions or whatever.
>> A relevant leak a leak irrelevant is not a friend of
Destiny.
I know I I some people in chat don't like Rely. He's not a friend
of Destiny,
This is not the case. I don't know why
you guys have to be the way you are
>> I don't know if these contracts are like actually uniquely
different per person, so I don't want to risk like burning my
contact on this, but I see um
We have So, there's a confidentiality clause. It lists out definitions.
>> Wait, didn't he
Didn't he just say he didn't see the confidentiality clause?
Am I Now, we don't have the YouTube video, so I don't have like
a transcript. I thought he was saying, "I don't see a confidentiality
clause." And then he went and said, "Now I see a confidentiality
clause." Am I crazy?
Hold on. I'll go back. I'll go back. Give me a second. >> I
don't see a confidentiality thing in this unless they're misreading
the under definitions or whatever.
>> I don't see a confidentiality thing in this unless they're
misreading under definitions or whatever.
>> I don't know if these contracts are like actually uniquely
different per person, so I don't want to risk like burning contact
on this, but I see um >> So, he doesn't want to risk burning
his contact, which by the way is why Taylor didn't publish it.
>> We have So, there's a confidentiality clause. It lists
out definitions. Um
>> Confidentiality clause, it lists out
>> Then it all seems boilerplate and standard to me. Proprietary
information or trade secrets.
>> Maybe it's Maybe that's what it's confidentiality around.
Looking for funding stuff. >> Proprietary sensitive information
for either disclosing party. >> I don't know how far we
go in here.
>> That one gets deleted his YouTube. The guy that thing
I just looked at. Really? This is such a bigger quote than supposed
to look at version of contracts in Instagram slideshow. Do we
look at actually we look at this a long time ago. This one doesn't
have a non-disparagement I don't think. >> First draft
contract I saw is the non-disparagement clause. I didn't see
this reported in the um
I think Wait. I think this was talked about in Was this talked
about in somebody's reporting? Maybe not Taylor's?
Or was this Was this a part of I think they said they talked
through stuff in group chats like about some non-disparagement
clause that was removed. But I can't remember if this was in
Taylor's article or not or some other article that was written
alongside it.
I remember hearing about this.
But I think it was like something they brought up and this was
addressed.
What's the next link?
Oh, is this right? About 8 minutes forward. So there's this that
Taylor Lorenz actually received dark money. We're just going
to go Listen, when you don't have the brain trust anymore, sometimes
you just got to trust a Reddit schizo out of nowhere, okay?
In the debate, Destiny seems to believe that the Wikimedia Foundation
being a 501c3 means they are dark money and that we cannot know
the source of income for this foundation.
I don't think that was his understanding in the debate. I think
he thought it was about the LLC. It's also weird, but
Really, Lunar Es? Really?
Really? I I trusted you. I just trusted you.
Okay. I trusted you. I can't believe you, man. I absolutely [__]
up, dude. Okay, so he's just reading this [__] Reddit
thread, I guess.
And he just reads this right there. I don't I don't know if there's
anything else here. I don't have like other stuff to cover. So,
I'm not particularly ready to move on, but
I don't know if this is getting any more interesting, okay? >> If
we'll have to see if there's anything else here that is actually
actually did have contributions such as 2020. Notable sources
of revenue contributions received $1.16 million.
This contribution here to this fund
came from What just happened? Clicked on something, started heavy
[snorts]
Dude, what the f-
Always going to be the same schedule B. Okay, all right. We're
going to go to the the timestamp at the end. I think we're basically
done with this, okay?
Give me a second. Give me a second. One more timestamp. Just
his summary at the very end, which is
really funny given how hard he went through this whole thing.
I saw this part for sure. I think I'm done with this. We're good.
I don't know if me and Taylor will ever argue again on this,
but
I think I think we're done with this, guys. By the way, I think
we missed this, but I do know multiple times throughout all of
this, he very carefully clarifies, "I don't think Pierre Omidyar
is bad. I don't think like the Omidyar Foundation is bad. I actually
I don't think dark money or anything with Pierre Omidyar just
in case you guys thought I thought Pierre I thought Pierre Omidyar
was bad. Oh, Pierre Omidyar isn't bad. I feel like somebody around
him is in some program that's funded by Pierre Omidyar and
basically
was like, "Hey, just so you know, this is really transparent
and we get money from this guy and you shouldn't be like so hard
on him." I feel like that happened.
>> You can call the 1630 Fund because it is a 501c4.
You can call this a dark money fund, but it would be incorrect
to say that the 1630 Fund ever funded Chorus.
If If want, you can say that Chorus >> I don't know that
that's true. >> dark money fund because they're organized
as a C4.
>> Okay, so
the exact things Taylor Lorenz did that you criticized her for,
that you tried to jump down her throat for,
are your conclusions now. That 1630 and cores are dark money.
I think he she actually backed off cores being dark money eventually.
I don't know if that's reflected in the article or not.
But that's funny. >> Although she said that they weren't
dark
But maybe that's because when she originally wrote the article,
they weren't they didn't have their own C4 status yet. I'm being
charitable maybe. Um for the Omidyar Network Fund,
because that's organized as a C3, you can see where their money
comes from. But their money comes from Omidyar Trust and Omidyar
Network Fund LLC, which are both technically dark money funds
cuz we have no idea what goes in or out of
They're not dark money funds.
I don't know how to say this.
I I and I I can only describe it this one way.
What would be the upside to including money from other people
in his trust, in the Omidyar Trust, the pure Omidyar Trust, right?
That's his >> But the main takeaway from all of this is
that dark money is a term and this is a
>> Oh, oh, the main takeaway is that it it it's a term
and this is a topic. Is that why you started two different fights,
like trying to call Taylor Lorenz out? When I when I heard this,
okay,
when I heard this, yeah, see, it's a topic he chose to force
twice. And Taylor Lorenz showed up twice, okay?
Bro, Taylor Lorenz showed up twice, won twice, and I don't know
how to describe this final conclusion
any other way than complete and utter capitulation.
Taylor Lorenz won. Destiny lost. He totally got destroyed.
All right? And every DG Gear, every single DG Gear crying about
this, crying about my coverage of this, crying about oh no, you
you're just so mind broken cuz you think Taylor won. You think
Taylor was right. You don't think Taylor's like a manipulative
psychopath. She's like the next Kelly Jean. Don't you know that
that she's like manipulative and crazy like Kelly Jean? Cuz Destiny
told me that and I believe him.
All of these people, Soylent Green as soon as possible, okay?
As soon as possible, first candidates to become meal replacement
for other human beings, all right? As soon as humanly
Anyway, I guess we'll finish this up,
I just got to hit that once for all the people. They were really
looking forward to this. Holy sh
Jesus Christ. Schizo rambling presidential address.
Wow, guys.
Actually, this whole topic was really stupid. This whole topic
I picked the fight on. This whole topic that I said everybody
else was wrong on, that I basically got, you know, totally schooled
on by Tom Foolery. Well, I guess in conclusion, you know, I maybe
I'm not the only one who was wrong. Maybe everybody was kind
of wrong. Maybe maybe like everybody was stupid here, guys. Maybe
I'm not the Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. best debater on the
planet, by the way. Going to going to lead the Democrats over
Trump, by the way.